[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم السي ابي
عاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من ادلب التي تريدنا
منها هذه الصور بعد موجه قصف للنظام
السوري على ريف ادلب اسفرت عن سقوط خمسه
قتلى وعشرات
الجرحى ونتابع هذه الصور من رام الله في
اعقاب يوم من تصعيد الاحتلال في الضفه
الغربيه خصوصا في حواره وطول
كر وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه
الليله حمص ساحه استهداف هو الاكبر ضد
قوات النظام السوري من منذ سنوات 80 قتيلا
ونحو 200 جريح في هجوم بالمسيرات على حفل
تخرج بالكليه الحربيه وفي المقابل قصف
مدفعي وصاروخي للنظام السوري على ريف ادلب
يوقع خمسه قتلى وعشرات
الجرحى تصعيد متزايد في الضفه الغربيه
عنوانه الاقتحامات الاحتلال يدفع بقواته
الى جنوب نابلوس ويقتل فلسطينيا في حواره
واستشهاد فلسطيني واصابه خمسه جنود
اسرائيليين في اشتباك منفصلين بطول
كرم ومجلس الامن القومي الامريكي يدعو في
تصريح للجزيره الى التهدئه وضبط
النفس قصف روسي على خاركيف يوقع عشرات
القتلى الرئيس الاوكراني يطالب بدفاعات
جويه اضافيه وبوري يقول ان اوروبا غير
قادره على تعويض ما تعجز واشنطن عن تقديمه
لكيف روسيا تتجه لاقامه قاعده بحريه في
اقليم ابخازيا الانفصالي في جورجيا بعد
اسبوعين من استهداف مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود في
القرم بعد مباحثات في غرناطه غاب عنها
عليف رئيس المجلس الاوروبي يؤكد للجزيره
انه سيدعو ارمينيا واذربيجان للاجتماع في
بروكسل نهايه الشهر باكو تبدي استعدادها
للتفاوض وماكرون يتهم اذربيجان بخرق
القانون الدولي ويرفض خيار العقوبات
ضدها في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرقميه ناقشنا دلالات اعلان هيئه
الاركان الفرنسيه بدا سحب قوتها من النيجر
هذا الاسبوع كمقدمه للانسحاب الكامل
للقوات الفرنسيه من النيجر قبل نهايه
العام الجاري لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
كيف ينعكس القرار الفرنسي ببد الانسحاب من
النيجر
63% توقعوا مزيدا من الضغوط على القوات
الفرنسيه في باقي دول غرب افريقيا بينما
راى
37% انه تمهيد لتصعيد ميداني في
النيجر هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمزي كيو ار الظاهر على
الشاشه لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد
يوم ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل
عربيا
ودوليا وتتابعون في الحصاد
ايضا السودان اسئله بشان جغرافيا صراع
يتسع ومقات سياسيه
غامضه
[موسيقى]
هجوم غير مسبوق منذ سنوات على قوات النظام
في سوريا اذ افادت مديريه الصحه التابعه
لحكومه النظام في حمص ان 80 قتيلا
و240 جريحا سقطوا في هجمات شنتها مسيرات
على حفل تخرج ضباط في الكليه الحربيه
بمدينه حمص ونقلت وكاله سانا الرسميه عن
بيان لجيش النظام ان تنظيمات وصفتها
بالارهابي المسلحه المدعومه من اطراف
دوليه معروفه استهدفت
الحفل ما جاب شي ما جابوا شي مشكله مايز
خيفه الانيه
[موسيقى]
هلا في هذه الاثناء افاد الدفاع المدني
السوري ان الحصيله الاوليه لض القصف
المدفعي والصاروخي المكثف والمستمر من قبل
قوات النظام على مدن وبلدات ريف ادلب بلغت
خمسه قتلى بينهم طفل وامراه
وثمانيه و38 جريحا بينهم ثمانيه اطفال
وثمان نساء اضاف الدفاع المدني ان القصف
استهدف ايضا قرى وبلدات النيرب وكفر لتا
وماره النعمان وحميل وافيس وغيرها في ريف
محافظه
ادلب ينضم الينا من غازي عنتاب سعد الشارع
الكاتب والباحث السياسي سيد سعد ماذا عن
هذا الهجوم على الكليه الحربيه في حمص
بالنظر الى السياق
والتوقيت نعم يعني لا اعتقد ان توقيت هذا
الهجوم هو يعني غريب عن الواقع الامني في
في سوريا رغم ان هذا الهجوم وقع في في وسط
سوريا في المحافظه التي يحافظ يحاول دائما
النظام السوري ان ان يبقيها بعيده في
الفتره الاخيره عن اي اشكاليات عسكريه
وامنيه لكن حقيقه قرب جبهات او الاماكن
التي ينتشر فيها تنظيم داعش تمكنه من
ايصال مسيرات الى عمق هذه المنطقه وايضا
الواقع الامني في سوريا يشير الى امكانيه
تشغيل هذه المسيرات من داخل مناطق النظام
السوري اي ان السجال الامني في يعني
الاطراف في سوريا هو لا يلتزم الضروره
بشكل الخارطه العسكريه المفروضه حاليا في
سوريا التي توصلت اما باتفاقيات دوليه او
عبر المعارك العسكريه جميع الاطراف تقريبا
في سوريا الدوليه منها والمحليه ايضا باتت
تمتلك درونات على اختلاف هنا انواعها
وانماطها يعني حقيقه جميع التصريحات التي
خرجت والتي اتهمت فيها كان هناك اتهامات
متبادله بين الاطراف ل للجهه التي تقف
وراء هذا يعني هذا هذه العمليه كل هذه
الامور تشير الى الى احتماليه ان يكون
التصعيد الامني في سوريا هو المستقبل
القريب الذي الذي تنتظره جميع
الاطراف جميع الاطراف تمتلك هذه المسيرات
سيد سعد تقول ان جميع الاطراف في سوريا
باتت تمتلك مثل هكذا مسيرات ولكن ما
دلالات ان يتزامن هذا الهجوم في حمص مع
اعلان القوات الامريكيه في الشمال السوري
عن اسقاط مسيره تركيه في
المنطقه
يعني اعتقد ان الحدثين منفصلين بشكل بشكل
كامل لعده اسباب هنا المواقع الجغرافيه
التي حدث فيها كلا العمليتين الاولى نتكلم
فيها عن منطقه الجزيره السوريه والاطراف
المتواجده في هذه المنطقه سواء قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه المدعومه من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه و ايضا حزب العمال
الكردستاني الذي هو مصنف على قوام الارهاب
والذي تستهدفه بشكل جدا كبير تركيا
وتعتبره العدو الاول بين العمليه التي تمت
هي في في حمص فالاطراف المحتمله او
المشاركه في هذه العمليه بعيده هنا الامر
يعني متباين تقريبا ربما يمكن ربط ما حدث
في حمص مع ما يحدث حاليا في السويداء
مظاهرات السويداء وايضا الحالات المتكرره
ل لحاله التعارض للنظام السوري من داخل
الحواضن التي هو يعتمد عليها تحدثون
تحديدا عن الساحل السوري باتت عمليات خروج
الناشطين من داخل حواضن النظام السوري
التي تعارض هذا النظام وتطالب حتى بعضها
بعض هذا الاصوات طالبت حتى باسقاط هذا
النظام السوري ربما يكون هنا مؤشر او يمكن
ربط هذه الحادثه بمحاوله النظام السوري
تنبيه حواضن المجتمعيه الى وجود بين
هلالين ما زال هناك وجود اعداء وما زال
هناك من يتربص بهذه المجتمعات لكن بعيدا
عن هذه عمليه الربط بالعوده هنا الى موضوع
الاطراف العسكريه والامنيه التي لديها
المقدره بالوصول الى هذه المناطق وتشغيل
حتى هذه المسيرات من داخل مناطق النظام
السوري جميع هذه الامور ربما تشير كدلال
واضحه واقعيه على احتماليه ان يكون هناك
تصعيد تصعيد امني جدا كبير في سوريا وهذا
الهدف يعني هو بحسب القراءه بحسب قراءه
حتى محللين عسكريين هو هدف عسكري بحث رغم
وجود مدنيين كانوا يشاركون ابنائهم في في
حفل في حفل التخرج لكن ايضا تعطي هذه ال
مؤشرات جدا كبيره الى ان يعني حرب
الدرونات تنتشر الان في سوريا في الاجواء
السوريه بشكل جدا كبير اعداد كبيره من
الدرونات رب وما يكون ايضا هو المستقبل
خلال الفتره الماضيه في فتره هدوء الجبهات
نسبيا معظم الاطراف حاولت ان تطور هذا
السلاح وان تمتلك هذا السلاح لذلك اعتقد
ان معظم هذه الاطراف لديها المقدره على
امتلاك وتشغيل هذه الدرونات شكرا شكرا لك
من غازي عن تاب سعد الشارع الكاتب والباحث
السياسي وفي حدث لافت في سوريا ايضا اكد
مسؤول امريكي للجزيره اسقاط مسيره تركيه
فوق شمال شرق سوريا وقال المسؤول الامريكي
ان المسيره التركيه كانت تحلق على مسافه
قريبه من القوات الامريكيه وانها لم تبتعد
رغم اتصالات امريكيه متكرره مع الجانب
التركي في المقابل قالت مصادر من وزاره
الدفاع التركيه ان المسيره المسلحه التي
اسقطت في سوريا لا تتبع للقوات المسلحه
التركيه من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم
البنتاغون باتريك رايدر ان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي بحث هاتفيا مع نظيره التركي
الانشطه التركيه قرب القوات الامريكيه في
سوريا اضاف ان مقاتله امريكيه من طراز اف
16 اسقطت المسيره التركيه التي كانت تحلق
على بعد نصف كيلومتر من القوات الامريكيه
في سوريا وقال انه ليست لدى البنتاغون
مؤشرات على ان تركيا كانت تنوي استهداف
القوات الامريكيه عمدا واوضح المتحدث ان
وزير الدفاع الامريكي اقر بهواجس تركيا
الامنيه المشروعه شدد مع نظيره التركي على
التنسيق المشترك لمنع وقوع تهديد للقوات
الامريكيه كما قال ان واشنطن تدين اي عمل
ارهابي ضد تركيا مشيرا الى ان حزب العمال
الكردستاني يمثل تهديدا
ارهابيا في هذه الاثناء قالت وسائل اعلام
تركيه ان الاستخبارات التركيه شنت ضربات
بالمسيرات على مواقع لوحدات حمايه الشعب
في شمال سوريا وكانت وسائل اعلام مواليه
ما تعرف بقوات سوريا ديمقراطيه قد اعلنت
مقتل اربعه اشخاص في قصف شنته طائرات
مسيره تركيه على مشير فحما شمال مدينه
الحسكه كما سقط قتل وجرح اخرون في قصف
استهدف ثلاثه مواقع في قريه تل الحبش
جنوبيه عاوده بريف الحسكه وتعرضت نقطه
عسكريه تابعه لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في ريف القامشلي لقصف
بالمسيرات
[موسيقى]
الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله حيث تتسع
دائره التصعيد في الضفه الغربيه اذ دفعت
قوات الاحتلال بتعزيزات الى بلده حواره
وقتلت فلسطينيا للاشتباه في انه نفذ عمليه
اطلاق نار استهدفت مركبه اسرائيليه حسب
قولها جاء ذلك بعد اقت حامي الاحتلال مخيم
طول كرم وقد شهدت المنطقه اشتباك منفصلين
اسفر عن استشهاد فلسطينيين واصابه خمسه
جنود
اسرائيليين موجه جديده من التصعيد
الاسرائيلي تترافق مع اقتحامات واسعه
ينفذها مستوطنون في الضفه الغربيه ويلفت
في هذه المرحله اعلان المقاومه استراتيجيه
وقواعد اشتباك جديده جنوبه الكرم قتلت
قوات الاحتلال شابين فلسطينيين بعد اقتحام
قريه شوفا اثر اطلاق نار عند مدخل مستوطنه
افني حفيت في عمليه تبنتها حركه حماس اثر
ذلك هاجمت قوه من جيش الاحتلال مخيم طول
كرم واعلنت فصائل المقاومه انها خاضت
اشتباكات عنيفه اضطرت على اثرها القوات
المهاجمه الى الدفع بتعزيزات لتامين
انسحاب جنودها واقرت باصابه خمسه منهم بعد
استهداف عربه عسكريه بعبوه ناسفه سبق ذلك
اقتحام نابلس من قبل 3000 مستوطن دخلوا
المدينه بحمايه جنود الاحتلال بذري الصلاه
في قبر يوسف واقتحم الجيش الاسرائيلي مخيم
بلاطه وقام بعمليات تخريب واستهداف مدنيين
ولا يزال الوضع في نابلس
متوترا وتكشف خلال غالبيه هذه الاقتحامات
نمط جديد من الهجمات
الاسرائيليه باتت سريعه تنفذ على شكل
عمليه خاطفه ثم تنسحب مباشره العمل
الميداني هذا يرجعه مراقبون الى تزايد قوه
المقاومه في الضفه والتي وصلت الى مرحله
نجحت فيها بهندسه عبوات ناسفه موجهه قا
على استهداف اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه واعطا
بها كما حدث في مخيم جنين وراهن في
اشتباكات
نابلس الجانب الفلسطيني يرى في التصعيد
هذا محاوله اسرائيليه لتقليص قدرته على
مقاومه الجيش الاسرائيلي بينما يرى اخرون
ان الخطه الاسرائيليه تهدف الى التمهيد
لعمليه ضم الضفه الغربيه خاصه في ظل حكومه
عمادها الحرك الدينيه المتطرفه التي لا
تخفي في برنامجها المعلن ضم بعض مناطق
الضفه
الغربيه في القدس اقتحم مئات المستوطنين
والمتطرفين اليهود المسجد الاقصى في اليوم
السادس من عيد العرش اليهودي وسط حراسه
امنيه مشدده وقال مسؤول في الاوقاف
الاسلاميه ان قوات كبيره من شرطه الاحتلال
تنتشر في باحات المسجد الاقصى وعند ابوابه
وتفرض قيودا مشدده على دخول الفلسطينيين
الى المسجد وقد ادى مئات المستوطنين صلوات
تلمود عند باب
القطانين ودعت حركه حماس الفلسطينيين الى
النفير والرباط يوم غد الجمعه داخل المسجد
الاقصى دفاعا عنه وقالت حماس ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ثبتت قواعد اشتباك جديده مع
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الضفه لمنعه
من دخول المخيمات
هذا وقال متحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي للجزيره ان واشنطن تدين جميع
اعمال العنف في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
واسرائيل اضاف ان الولايات المتحده تشعر
بالقلق اذاء اي تصاعد للعنف وتدعو الاطراف
الى تهدئه التوترات وممارسه ضبط النفس
ولفت المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي الى ان بلاده تجري محادثات
مستمره مع شركائها الاسرائيليين ومع سلطه
الفلسط
واشار الى انه يجب السعي لتحقيق المسائله
والعداله بنفس القدر من الصرامه في جميع
حالات التطرف العنيف ايا كان
مرتكبها ينضم الينا من رام الله الدكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه مرحبا بك دكتور مصطفى
اذا قواعد اشتباك جديده يجري تثبيتها في
الضفه ما هي هذه القواعد وما مدى
فعاليتها
هناك معلمان رئيسيان لما يجري المعلم
الاول ان اسرائيل تشن حرب دمويه ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني بكل
مكوناته وهدفها الضم والتهويد الكامل
للضفه الغربيه بما فيها القدس طبعا
والمسجد الاقصى والجانب الاخر ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تتنوع وتتصاعد وتصبح مؤثره
اكثر وهذا ما رايناه اليوم باصابه خمسه من
الجنود الاسرائيليين بعضهم جراحهم خطيره
هذا يثبت امر واضح وهو ان اسرائيل تفشل في
وقف المقاومه الفلسطينيه الباسله فشل
الاحتلال رغم قمعه وتنكيلا واستخدامه لكل
انواع الاسلحه ورغم ان انه اوقع 248 شهيد
حتى هذه اللحظه منذ بدايه العام في صفوف
الفلسطينيين ثانيا يفشل التنسيق الامني في
وقف المقاومه وثالثا حتى عمليات التطبيع
التي جرت او التي يروج لها لا تؤثر في
المقاومه التي تتصاعد وتستمر بل بالعكس
تؤدي الى تزايدها في المحصله العامه لكن
عندما تتزايد دكتور مصطفى العمليات عمليات
المقاومه في هذا السياق العام او المشهد
العام الذي اشرت اليه وفي ظل اختلال
موازين القوى الهائل ما الفارق الذي
تحدثه الفارق هائل اولا هذا يؤكد ان
القضيه الفلسطينيه لن تموت وان الخطه
الاسرائيليه لن تنجح ما دام الشعب
الفلسطيني صامد على ارض وطنه لا يرحل وما
دام الشعب الفلسطيني يقاوم فالمشروع
الصهيوني مشروع فاشل رغم كل العوامل
الاخرى التي تجند من اجل خدمه المشروع
الاسرائيلي ورغم الانحياز الامريكي المطلق
وكان شيء غريب التصريح الامريكي الذي
يساوي بين الطرفين يساوي بين المحتل والذي
تحت الاحتلال بين القامع ومن هو يتعرض
للبطش والتنكيل اهم اهم شيء في هذه المق
المقاومه انها تؤكد بقاء القضيه
الفلسطينيه وتؤكد ان المشروع الصهيوني
فاشل المشروع الصهيوني يقوم على عنصرين
الاستيلاء على الارض بالقوه ونجحوا في ذلك
ولكن الشرط الثاني
ان يزول الشعب الفلسطيني ويهجر او يتوقف
عن المقاومه ويرضخ وهذا لا يحدث بالعكس
هذه المقاومه تتصاعد وبكل اشكالها دكت
دكتور مصطفى اشرت الى الموقف الامريكي
ولكن الا ترى ان هناك ربما اختلاف بسيط في
النبره عندما يتحدث عن انه يجب السعي
لتحقيق المسائله والعداله بنفس القدر من
الصرامه في جميع
الحالات هذا لا يكفي الولايات المتحده هي
اكثر طرف يستطيع ان يضغط على اسرائيل لو
ارادت هل يفعل شيء بشان الاستيطان
المستشري لا هل قاموا باي اجراء ضد عمليات
القتل والتنكيل التي يتعرض لها
الفلسطينيون لا اليوم الجيش الاسرائيلي
دخل مدينتين مدينه رام الله والبيره والتي
يفترض ان تكون تحت سيطره السلطه
الفلسطينيه ومدينه بيت لحم ماذا يعني ذلك
يعني ان كل الاراضي تحت الاحتلال والسلطه
لا قيمه لوجودها ماذا فعلت الولايات
المتحده اذاء ذلك لا شيء اهم شيء لا تقوم
به الولايات المتحده انها لا تفرض على
اسرائيل عقوبات كي توقف الاستيطان
المستشري الذي هدفه الرئيسي والمركزي هو
الضم والتهويد لا تقوم باي شيء اذا
الاعتداءات على المسجد الاقصى وبالتالي
حتى لو كان في تغير في اللهجه لكن لا توجد
اجراءات عمليه ولو كان هناك تغير جدي
راينا تهديد
بالعقوبات وراينا الولايات المتحده تجبر
اسرائيل على وقف التوسع الاستيطاني ولكن
هذا لا يحدث حتى الان شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ضيفنا من رام
الله
الى السودان حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره ان
الجيش قصف بالمدفعيه الثقيله اهدافا تابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع في مناطق متفرقه من
العاصمه الخرطوم وغربيه ام دورمان وافادت
مصادر محليه للجزيره ان طائرات مسيره
تابعه للجيش السوداني استهدفت مواقع الدعم
السريع بمحيط سلاح المدرعات جنوبي العاصمه
وافاد مراسل الجزيره ان قوات الدعم السريع
قصفت بالمدفعيه مناطق شماليه ام دورمان ما
اسفر عن سقوط جرحى من
المدنيين هذا وتتواصل يوميات الحرب في
السودان دون نهايه قريبه لها تلوح في
الافق بل تسعت جغرافيتها في دارفور
وكردفان بكل ما تتركه من دمار وماس
انسانيه وتشكل الحرب اختبارا للعقل
السياسي السوداني من حيث هي ازمه في السيا
وفي العسكريه تدور حول السلطه ولذلك فان
اكبر التحديات التي سيواجهها السودان هي
اسئله ما بعد الحرب اسئله اليوم التالي
لوقفها وهي اسئله في السياسه لا يبدو حتى
الان ان هناك تصورات عمليه بشانها تقرير
فوزي
بشرى كل حرب هي تعبير عنيف عن نهايه
السياسه وقد تكون نزوعا سلطويا محض
يتوسل بالقوه الى حيازه السلطه كامله وفي
الحرب السودانيه النابه اليوم عناصر من كل
ذلك فهي حرب نتاج ازمه سياسيه محكمه وهي
صراع على السلطه يتدثر بالمظالم التنمويه
والسياسيه كما يعبر عنها خطاب الدعم
السريع وهو خطاب اصطنع على عجل بين يدي
الحرب فليس للدعم السريع من سابقه في
الانقال بما هو سياسي يقول معارضوه
والحال كذلك فان الازمين السياسيه
والسلطوية
[موسيقى]
ان تجربه تاسيس انتقال ديمقراطي بعد
الاطاحه بحكم الرئيس عمر البشير كانت
تجربه فاشله في راي قطاع من السودانيين
كبير فقد فشلت سلطه الانتقال في اقامه
مجلس تشريعي انتقالي وفشلت في تحقيق
العداله للضحايا لا سما ضحايا مجزره
القياده العامه كما فشلت في ادائها
الاقتصادي حتى وقع في الحريه والتغيير
التي استبدت بالسلطه الخلافات ومن ثم
الانقسامات ثم جاء انقلاب البرهان او ما
سماه هو بالاجراءات التصحيحيه لينهي مسيره
الانتقال على علاتها وكان تمام المشهد
السياسي بفشل رئيس الوزراء عبد الله حمدوك
مرتين فلا هو نجح محمولا على موجه الثوره
العاليه ولا هو نجح مدعوا من البرهان
لتشكيل حكومه ما بعد الاجراءات يسميها
الشارع
انقلابا اما اخر مشهد للممارسه السياسيه
قبل الحرب فكان الجدل الواسع حول الاتفاق
الاطاري الذي شق المجتمع السوداني بسسته
قسمين معه وضده في ذلك الاتفاق كانت
المعضله الكبرى هي الترتيبات العسكريه
فيما يتعلق بالدعم السريع ويبدو في نظر
كثير من المراقبين ان تحالفا ما قد وقع
بين قائد الدعم السريع وبين قوى الحريه
والتغيير ان يكون الدعم السريع تابعا
لرئيس مجلس الوزراء المدني وليس لقائد
الجيش وهو ترتيب انست فيه القوى المدنيه
ما تصورته حمايه لها من الجيش اما حمتي
فقد كان الاتفاق يحقق له ما ظل يريده وهو
الاستقلال التام عن سلطه الجيش عليه تلك
كانت وصفه للحرب فما وجدت دوله بجيشين
وقيادتي عسكريتين هذا فضلا عن ماخذ كثيره
على المضامين الثقافيه والدينيه للاتفاق
الاطاري اما الخط السلطوي المرتبط بالازمه
المنشئه للحرب فيكمن في مشروع قائد قوات
الدعم السريع وهو مشروع قائم على مراكم
القوه العسكريه بما يتجاوز الوظيفه التي
انشئ بموجبها الدعم السريع وهي القضاء على
حركات الهامش المسلحه في دارفور كانت قوه
حميت التي نمت تحت رعايه وبصر البر
وتزكيته لها قد بلغت مدى لا ينقصه الا
تجسدها سلطه حاكمه وبمكياج ليه تتصل بحيل
صناعه الملك كان حميتي يتنقل بين الحواضن
حتى انتهى الى قوى الحريه والتغيير وهو
الذي كان شديد النقد لها يوم كان يتودد
الادارات الاهليه كان الفلول او انصار
النظام القديم موضع استشهاده على عدم رصد
تلك القوى الم
محل تهبش الطرق الصوفيه لا الفلول
الادارات الاهليه للا فلول الاحزاب
الفلانيه دي الفلول طيب انت تحكم منو ثم
جاءت الحرب ثمره لكل ذلك التخبط السياسي
والعسكري وايما كانت جهود المنابر الساعيه
لوضع نهايه للحرب سواء في جده عبر
المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه او من خلال
مبادره الايجاد المثيره للجدل او مبادره
دول جوار السودان التي انعقدت قمتها في
مصر قبل شهرين فان الازمه الكبرى هي سؤال
ما بعد نهايه الحرب اي حكم اي سلطه اي
انتقال ديمقراطي وهذه اسئله في التاسيس
المعتبر بتجربه الحرب لان جمله لا للحرب
جمله ناقصه حتى تاتي بقول في كيف يكون
الحال بعد وقفها تماما كما كانت جملته
تسقط
جمله ناقصه لم تفكر في كيفيه القيام بعد
الاسقاط ينضم الينا هنا في استديو الحصاد
الدكتور اسامه عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني
المختص بالشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه دكتور
اسامه هل دون وقف الحرب الان الدائره في
السودان الاجابه عن كل هذه الاسئله التي
طرحها زميلنا فوزي بشرى في التقرير ايجاد
حلول لكل هذه المشاكل التي كانت تواجه
السودان وادت فيما ادت اليه الى هذه
المواجهات العسكريه هي في الحقيقه
المقاربه الموجوده في السودان هي التي
خلقت الازمه وفي النهايه المقاربه
السياسيه والمنهج
السياسي للتنافس والصراع في السودان هو
الذي ادى في النهايه الى هذه الحرب كل
المشاريع الموجوده مطروحه في الساحه من
مجموعاتنا السياسيه واحزاب السياسيه هي
مشاريع هندسه اجتماعيه تستند على عنف
السلطه على دبابه على السلطه وعلى دبابه
العسكر من اجل ان تفرض هذه المشاريع ذات
الطبيعه التي تغير المجتمع بحسب رؤى هذه
الاحزاب ان كانت تريد المجتمع ان يتجه
يسارا او يتجه يمينا ان يكون ديمقراطيا
بحسب ما تراه هو غاب عن هذه الاحزاب انه
الاستعانه بالدبابه يجعل الدبابه شرسه جدا
وتريد المزيد من السلطه لنفس نفسها وهذا
ما يحدث في دورات متعاقبه للحكم في
السودان كان هذه الاحزاب لم تتعلم شيئا
يعني بعد ثوره عظيمه الان خرج الناس الى
الشارع وسقط النظام السابق جاءت هذه
الاحزاب بدل ان تبعد الجيش من السلطه
استندت على الجيش في وثيقه دستوريه لتتولى
الحكم لمده عامين انقلب عليها الجيش لم
يكفها ذلك عادت من جديد الى الجيش ليمنحها
سلطه مره اخرى وبما ان الجيش هذه المره
اصبح جيشين فقائد الجيش الثاني
يعني لا يريد ان يكون فقط الحامي وانما
يريد ان يستلم السلطه لنفسيه طيب في
المقابل هناك ايضا ربما من يرى بخلاف ذلك
من يرى ان هذه الاحزاب ربما كانت محكومه
بالذهاب في هذا المسار بسبب سلطه الجيش في
المرحله الماضيه ووجوده و امكاناته في
الداخل الدوله ولكن السؤال الان دكتور
اسامه ما السبيل الى الى الخروج من هذه
الازمه وهل دخلت هذه المواجهات العسكريه
مرحله
المراوحه هي هذه المواجهات العسكريه الى
نهايه الحرب الى نهايه قطعا ستنتهي و
والتاسيس لما بعد الحرب يب يعني لابد ان
يقوم على ان تعرف هذه الاحزاب جميعها انه
لا يمكن تولي السلطه الا عبر تفويض
انتخابي من الشعب السوداني نفسه صاحب
السلطه وانه لا الجيش يمنحها السلطه ولا
غيره من الجيوش يمكن ان يمنحها السلطه
وتصبح هذه السلطه شرعيه لان الجيش لا يملك
شرعيه استلام السلطه ومنحها التاسيس يكون
بتاسيس مناخ للتنافس السياسي الحر بفرص
متكافئه لكل الاحزاب السياسيه دون وصايه
من نفوذ دون وصايه من مال دون وصايه من
سلاح لنصل الى مرحله التاسيس هذه لابد ان
تفهم هذه الاحزاب انه يجب عليها ان تجلس
مع بعضها وان تطرح كل شيء على مائده التفا
شكرا لك اسامه عيدروس دكتور اسامه عيدروس
الاكاديميه السودانيه المختص بالشؤون
السياسيه والعسكريه شكرا
[موسيقى]
جزيلا
حذرت مديره صندوق النقد الدولي كريستالينا
جورجيفا من ان مصر في خطر خساره
احتياطياتها من العملات الاجنبيه وقالت في
مقابله صحفيه ان مصر سوف تستنزف احتياط ها
من النقد الاجنبي ما لم تخفض قيمه عملتها
المحليه اضافت ان اقتصاد تونس مضطرب لكن
الوضع اقل خطوره مما هو عليه في مصر الا
انه لا يزال بحاجه الى اجراءات عاجله
لاستكمال الترتيبات المتعلقه بحزمه انقاذ
مالي قيمتها مليار و900 مليون دولار من
البنك
الدولي
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من القاهره
الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب استاذ
الاقتصاد السياسي ومن ديترويت معنا
الدكتور مصطفى يوسف الباحث في الاقتصاد
السياسي ومدير المركز الدولي للدراسات
التنمويه والاستراتيجيه مرحبا بكما دكتور
مصطفى يوسف ما خطوره هذا التحذير الوارد
على لسان
جورجيفا بالنظر الى ان معظم الاحتياطي
النقدي الاجنبي في مصر هو على شكل
ودائع من دول اجنبيه وضعت هذه الاحتياطيات
النقديه الاجنبيه في مصر وبالتالي ما
خطوره هذا التحذير وما انعكاسه على هذه
الودائع
يعني كما تفضلتي اكثر من 80% من الاحتياط
النقدي عباره عن ودائع خليجيه وهذا
التحذير يرسل رسال سلبيه للاسف لدول
الخليج بان اموالكم لن تكون في امان اذ لم
تاخذ يعني الحكومه المصريه والنظام المصري
اجراءات عاجله ل يعني وضع الجنيه بقيمته
الحقيقيه الجنيه المصري الان يعني سعره
يتراوح ما بين ال 40 و 42 وفي تقديرات
اخرى قرابه ال 45 46 وهذا ما يتداول به
سهم السي اي بي البنك المصري في برصه لندن
مقاوم الجنيه على حدود 46 دولار على
الجنيه على حدود 46 جنيه للدولار الامريكي
يعني يعني الصندوق اخذ تعهدات من مصر منذ
قرابه العام منذ نهايه العام الماضي من
ديسمبر العام الماضي حينما اقر حزمه تمويل
جديده بثلاثه مليار ومعها يعني التزام من
الشركاء الاقليميين وهم دول الخليج في
المقام الاول بدعم الحكومه المصريه على
اساس انه يتم تعويم الجنيه المصري الامر
الاول الامر الثاني ان تتخارج المؤسسه
العسكريه تماما من الاقتصاد وان يتم بيع
بعض الاصول حتى يتحرك الاقتصاد ولكن حينما
تم يعني تخفيض مبدئي للجنيه المصري على
الدولار الامريكي واصبحت سعره تقريبا 31
جنيه حدثت يعني
بعض القلاقل الاجتماعيه استشعرت استشعر
النظام المصري والحكومه المصريه بان يعني
لو طرك الجنيه على الدولار لفوق ال 40
فستن خفض مستوى معيشه الناس نظرا لان يعني
للاسف نظرا لغياب خطط التنميه الشامله
تستورد مصر قرابه 70% من الاغذيه فسيرتفع
سعر كل شيء اكثر من 30% وهذا امر لا
يستطيع النظام المصري تحمله لان هناك
انفاق غير رشيد تم للاموال القليله التي
كانت تمتلكها الحكومه المصريه ثم تم
الاقتراض بشراهه غير منطقيه تم الاقتراض
داخليا اكثر من 6 تريليون وخارجيا الدين
الخارجي المصري الان اكثر من 166 مليار
دولار فيعني هذا سيؤدي الى زعزعه النظام
وعليه تاخر وتلك كثيرا في هذا الامر وبناء
على ذلك يعني صدر هذا التصريح من مديره
صندوق النق دكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب ما
وقع هذا التصريح لدى السلطات المصريه وكيف
باعتقادك ستتصرف
معه يعني هو بالتاكيد هو تصريح بيحمل
مشكله خطيره جدا وكانه بيحمل تحذير
للحكومه المصريه بانها يجب ان تمضي قدما
في تنفيذ التعهدات التي تعهدت بها الى
صندوق النقض الدولي وا اعتقد ان الدكتور
مصطفى يعني شرح الجزئين المهمين وهو طرح
اسهم بعض شركات الجهات السياديه في
البورصه وانتهاج سياسه سعر لصرف المرن
بتاتي خطوره هذه التصريحات رغم انها كانت
تصريحات يعني بمناسبه الاعداد لاجتماعات
الخريف المقرره في المغرب لكن المشكله ان
تصريحات مديره صندوق النقد الدولي خطورتها
انها تاتي في ظل الاستحقاق الرئاسي ومن
هنا انا في اعتقادي انها سوف تكون ذو
تاثير سيء جدا سواء على الاحوال المعيشيه
او حتى على ثقه يعني الثقه الع اعتقادك
دكتور اعتقادك يا دكتور السلطات المصريه
يفترض ان تلبي هذا الطلب او
هذا هذه النصيحه التي قدمتها جورجيفا فورا
بشكل
عاجل يعني هو طبعا مستحيل يعني كل من تبع
التصريحات التي صدرت في مساله التعويم او
انتهاج سعر صرف مرن يعني من راس الدوله
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي قرر ان ان
التعويم قضيه امن قومي وهو قطر شديد جدا
ومن هنا انا يعني لذلك استغرب تصريحات
الدكتوره جورجيفا في هذه الظروف المفترض
ان مصر يعني على ابواب استحقاق رئاسي وفي
ظل هذه الظروف بتتجمع اما التصريحات
الدوليه بشان حاله الاقتصاد او حتى
المفاوضات لكن اذا كنا نريد ان نتحدث عن
المستقبل فانا اعتقد ان مصر اذا كانت تريد
المضي قدما في الحصول على دعم صندوق النقد
الدولي فهي مطالبه بالاستجابه لتعهداتها
بغض ننظر عن النصيحه من عدمه لكن انا في
اعتقادي ان ذلك لن يتم قبل مارس 2024 اي
بعد انتهاء الاستحقاق الرئاسي وربما تشكيل
حكومه جديده ما رايك دكتور مصطفى يوسف
يعني ربما تاخذ ياخذ موضوع تعويم الجنيه
الى مارس من العام المقبل وبالتالي ما
انعكاسات ذلك على ما سيحصل في مصر على
الاقتصاد المصري عموما بالنظر الى تحذيرات
جورجيفا مبدئيا يعني هناك بنوك مصريه
يعني بنكان اليوم منعوا استخدام يعني
بطاقات الائتمان المصريه في الخارج لاي
مشتريات و يعني ول ستريت جورنال اول امس
يوم 3 اكتوبر نشر التقرير في غايه الخطوره
على ان ما ما سيتم يعني خلال بضعه اسابيع
ليس انتخابات بالمعنى المفهوم ان المساله
محسومه وعليه فان الامر يعني اضعف الايمان
كما يقولون ان يتم تخارج الشركات التي
مملوكه للمؤسسه العسكريه وبعض الجهات
الاخرى الامنيه يعني يتم التخرج منها
ووضعها في الموازنه العامه للدوله هذا
الامر الاول الامر الثاني حينما يعني يعني
ترسل الحكومه المصريه بعض الرسائل
الايجابيه للمستثمرين الاجانب والدائنين
سيتم ضخ اموال اخرى يعني المساله ليست
ثلاثه مليار حينما يعني لماذا تحجم دول
الخليج اليوم عن شراء بعض الاصول المصريه
المربحه للغايه لان الجنيه المصري مقاوم
باقل من ثلث ثلث قيمته فحينما تسعر الجنيه
المصري بقيمته الحق ثم يحدث تخارج من هذه
الشركات سياتي لكن الان يعني نحن ما قاله
ول ستريت جورنال تقرير خطير جدا قال يعني
المحرر قال بشكل واضح ان هذه ليست
انتخابات وانه بعد هذه الانتخابات سيتم
تمديد الرئاسه الى ما لا نهايه كما حدث في
2019 يعني نحن امام مشهد خطير لانه لا
ينبغي اطلاقا ان تكون هناك دولتان دوله
تمتلكها المؤسسه العسكريه ويمتلك اقتصاد
قوي جدا والحكومه المصريه مدينه والامر
الاخر لا ينبغي ان يكون الجنيه مصعر بغير
قيمته الحقيقيه دكتور عبد النبي عبد
المطلب ان كانت الدوله المصريه ولدى
الاقتراض من صندوق النقد اصلا وافقت على
مبدا القيام بالاصلاحات المطلوبه ومن بين
هذه الاصلاحات تعويم الجنايه ما المشكله
في القيام
بهذا الاجراء الان ما هو اصلا معروف سلفا
انها ستقوم بذلك كما هو
مطلوب يعني هي الحكومه المصريه تعتقد انها
بالفعل نفذت عاودتها لصندوق النقد الد
الدولي عندما قامت بتخفيض قيمه الجنيه
لثلاث مرات متتاليه تقريبا فقد الجنيه ما
يقرب من 100% من قيمته يعني الحكومه
المصريه تعتقد انها قامت بذلك يعني وصل
سعر صرف الجنيه مقارنه بما قبل الاتفاق مع
صندوق النقد الدولي يعني حوالي 105% من
حوالي
15.7 الى الان 30.8 او
30.9 بذلك ترى الحكومه المصريه انها نفذت
التعهدات ايضا هناك دراسات بالفعل واه هذا
امر حقيقي قامت به الحكومه المصريه واجهزه
متخصصه داخل الدوله المصريه يعني تتخوف
بشكل كبير جدا من ان الاقدام على عمليه
تخفيض اخرى قد يتبعها مساله سقوط حر
للجنيه المصري وهذا سوف يعني يزيد المشاكل
ويزيد الاباء انها ربما ربما تحصل في مارس
من العام المقبل ما المشكله ان حصلت الان
يعني ما الفارق ان حصلت الان وربما
استدراك مخاطر هذا الموضوع بدل التاجي الى
مارس
باختصار لا المساله مختلفه بشكل كبير جدا
عندما نتحدث الان في ظل ازمات اقتصاديه
حاليه موجوده وفي ظل مشاكل تعاني منها
الحكومه المصريه حاليا في عدم توافر النقد
الاجنبي فان اي تخفيض في قيمه الجنيه لن
يؤتي ثماره لكن الحكومه المصريه تتمنى او
لديها امل انه في اعقاب الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه قد تتمكن من اصلاح بعض
الامور التي تمكنها من جذب الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه المباشره زياده تحولات المصريين
العاملين في الخارج دقيقه واحده بس لو
سمحت حضرتك زياده تحولات المصريين
العاملين في الخارج وايضا جذب بعض الاموال
من الشركاء الدوليين وفي مقدمتهم دول
الخليج وانا في اعتقادي ان مساله رفع سعر
الفائده على شهادات الدولاريه كان احد
العناصر التي يمكن ان تساعد في ذلك دكتور
دكتور مصطفى يوسف اشار ضيفنا الدكتور عبد
النبي الى توقيت تصريحات جورجييفا
مع الانتخابات المصريه الجاريه باعتقادك
اي وقع سيكون لهذه التصريحات على العمليه
انتخابيه رغم انك قلت انك يعني لست مؤمنا
بان ما يجري هو عمليه انتخابيه بل هو
تمديد مبدئيا يعني يعني المصريين عاملين
في الخارج كما تفضل الضيف الكريم دكتور
عبد النبي تحولهم قلت بمقدار الثلث لعدم
الثقه في اجراءات النظام النظام المصري
والحكومه المصريه هذا الواقع واقع سلبي
للغايه ولكن يعني الان نحن يعني امام يعني
نظام عسكري اي لا توجد انتخابات بالمعنى
المفهوم الانخابات التي تمت مرتان 97%
تقريبا النتائج فهذا ليست هذه ليست
انتخابات العالم كله لا يتعامل معها على
انها انتخابات ولكن الان الامر المهم
حينما تتخرج المؤسسه العسكريه من الاقتصاد
ويتم تسعير الجن بسعره الحقيقي ستاتي
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه سيكون هناك تفاؤل
لدى المستثمرين والدائنين الخارجيين لان
الوضع الاقتصادي المصري الان حينما يكون
تونس التي وضعها الاقتصادي هش للغايه افضل
من وضع مصر مصر الان يعني من اسوا
الاقتصادات الناشئه في العالم كله طبقا
للبنك الدولي وصندوق النق شكرا لك من
ديترويت الدكتور مصطفى يوسف الباحث في
الاقتصاد السياسي ومدير المركز الدولي
لدراسات التنمويه والاستراتيجيه وشكرا
للدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب استاذ
الاقتصاد السياسي ضيفنا من
القاهره الان الى هذه التطورات العاجله من
الضفه الغربيه حيث قالت مراسله الجزيره ان
عشرات المستوطنين يهاجمون منازل فلسطينيين
في بلده حواره جنوبيه نابلس تحت حمايه
قوات الاحتلال وكانت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه اعلنت عن استشهاد شاب فلسطيني
برصاص قوات الاحتلال في
البلده تنضم الينا من رام الله مراسله
الجزيره جيفارا البديري جيفارا قربين اكثر
من هذا المشهد الذي يب يبدو انه مكرر ماذا
يحصل في هذه الاثناء العشرات من
المستوطنين الملثمين المسلحين يقومون
بمهاجمه منازل فلسطين
في بلده حواره جنوبي نابلس وفق الاهالي
هناك هؤلاء المستوطنون يقومون ايضا باطلاق
الرصاص الحي على عدد من المنازل يرشقون
الحجاره على النوافذ على الابواب بعضهم
يقف عند ابواب بعض المنازل يحاول اقتحام
هذه المنازل بالطبع كل ذلك تحت حمايه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرا
مكبرات المساجد تناشد الاهالي تناشد القرى
القريبه تناشد اهالي نابلس بالتوجه الى
القريه لمساعده اهلها ومساندتهم من
المستوطنين الذين يهاجمون القريه
في امام كل اعين جنود الاحتلال وغم ان قبل
قليل في بيان مقتضب للناطق باسم قوات
الاحتلال اسرائيلي قار قرر الاحتلال اغلاق
كافه المحاور الرئيسيه واغلاق المحال
التجاريه في الشارع الرئيسي وهو شارع اصلا
البلده هي تربط جنوب نابلس
بوسط الضفه يعني من يعني بين نابلس ورام
الله هي الطريق الرئيسيه التي تؤدي الى
هذه القرى هناك الكثير من القرى ايضا
المحيطه بها المستوطنون في تلك المستوطنات
وهي الاكثر اي تطرف من بين كل المستوطنين
الذين يعيشون في اراضي الضفه الغربيه وفق
الاهالي الوضع غايه في الصعوبه ولكن ما
حدث هو انه
اي عصر هذا اليوم تم اطلاق النار على
سياره
لمستوطنين اي لم يصب احد باذى قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سارعت على الفور الى
عمليه التمشيط وقالت انها حاصرت شاب
فلسطيني في داخل منزل بزعم انه من قام
باطلاق النار على السياره بعد الاشتباك
معه قامت بقتله لا يعرف حتى الان مصير هذا
الشهيد الذي تم ابلاغ هيئه الشؤون المدنيه
الفلسطينيه عبر سلطات الاحتلال باستشهاده
وبالتالي ابلاغ وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه اي
ان الشهيد محتجز لدى قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وبذلك ير تتفع عدد الجسامي
الشهداء المحتجزه لدى قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى
146 شهيدا بالطبع الخشيه الان من مشهد
يتكرر منذ شباط اذار الماضي عندما حرق
المستوطنون عشرات المنازل في قريه حواره
ومن بعد ذلك ايضا في قريه طرمس عيا شمال
رام الله لا ننسى ايضا الوزير الاسرائيلي
اليميني المتطرف موتتش الذي دعى علانيه
وصراحه الى محو بلده حواره عن الوجود رغم
ان هذه البلده يعني تقع في مسار طريق طويل
و نوعا ما اهالي القريه هم سكان امنون لكن
الان هم ليسوا في مامن ويناشدون كما ذكرت
لك الي عبر مكبرات الصوت
بمحاوله بمط الا
والفلسطينيين بالوصول الى القريه لان
الامور تتصاعد ولكن ما حدث ايضا نعود
للتكسير بعد قتل الشاب الفلسطيني من قبل
جنود الاحتلال في قريه حواره توافد المئات
منص جيفارا اريد جيفارا لو سمحتي اريد ان
اشير الى هذه الصوره التي تظهر على شاشتنا
الان لعشرات
المستوطنين
وهم يعني بالقرب من قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في حواره قبل قليل وكما ذكرتي
يهاجمون منازل فلسطينيين في البلده جنوبي
نابلس تحت حمايه قوات الاحتلال هنا اريد
اريد ان اسال جفارا يعني ماذا يعني تحت
حمايه قوات الاحتلال ما دور قوات الاحتلال
في ما يقوم به المستوطنون عاده في مثل هذه
الهجمات التي كما
ذكرتي بتت تتكرر منذ شباط الماضي تحديدا
في حواره وترمس عيا بالهجوم على منازل
الفلسطينيين وحرق ممتلكات
الفلسطينيين ببساطه تامين الحمايه بالكامل
للمستوطنين للقيام بكل هذه الاعمال اعمال
التي يصفها الفلسطينيون بال العربده واان
كنت شاهده مع طاقم الجزيره خلال تلك
الفتره كنا نرى كيف ان قوات الاحتلال تقوم
بتامين الحمايه بالكامل للمستوطنين وفي
مقابل تقوم
بابعاد الفلسطينيين تحت تهديد السلاح
ومنعهم من حمايه انفسهم بمعنى انه يحذر
حتى على الفلسطيني من ان يحمي عائلته
واطفاله نذكر ايضا ان هناك على سبيل
المثال عندما حوصرت عائله اضطر الاب لان
يحتجز او يحمي اطفاله وعائلته عبر وضعهم
في حمام داخل المنزل او في غرفه صغيره
الليح فيها من محرقه كانت مؤكده وبالتالي
الان ما يحدث هو ذات المشرد قوات الاحتلال
تقوم بحمايه
المستوطنين المسلحين هم كلهم مسلحون
بالطبع في الضفه ال الغربيه في هذه
الاثناء هي تقوم بذات المشهد تمنع الاهالي
من حمايه منازلهم وبالتالي من حمايه
عائلاتهم توفر الحمايه والامن هم قاموا
يعني مساء هذا اليوم المئات من المستوطنين
توافدوا الى وسط البلده قاموا باداء طقوس
تلمود وشعائر بحجه الاحتفال بعيد العرش
اليهودي الذي هو اصلا الليله ينتهي ولكن
بالطبع هي المزاعم بسبب الاحتجاج على
اطلاق النار على سياره المستوطنين رغم انه
لم تقع اي اصابات او اضرار ولكن ان استمر
الوضع على هذا الحال وواصلت قوات الاحتلال
بحمايه المستوطنين هذا معناه ان امام مشهد
قد يتسارع بسرعه كبيره جدا ولن تحمض
عقباها لانه ايضا جيفارا ربما من المفيد
ان نسال عن وسائل الحمايه الفلسطينيه على
قلتها كما هو معروف في هذه الحالات ذكرت
ان الفلسطينيين يقومون
ب يعني مناشده عبر مكبرات الصوت
للفلسطينيين من اجل تامين الحمايه ولكن ما
الخيارات ماذا بيدهم ان يفعلوا
اكثر من عصي اكثر من ادوات منزليه في داخل
منزله منازلهم لا تتجاوز حتى يمكن ان
يستخدموا
احذيه ادوات المطبخ مازلنا نشاهد لو سمحتي
جيفاره ما زلنا نشاهد هذه الصور كما ذكرتي
لما يبدو انه صلوات تلميه يقوم بها
المستوطنون بمناسبه عيد العرش في حواره
قبل قليل هذا ما هو ظاهر في هذه الصور
التي نراها وكما ذكرتي كل ذلك
يحدث او حدثت هذه الصلوات قبل الهجمات
التي قام بها المستوطنون ويقومون بها في
هذه الاثناء على منازل وممتلكات
الفلسطينين في حواره تحت حمايه قوات
الاحتلال نعم كنا نتحدث جيفاره عن وسائل
الحمايه على قلتها الموجوده لدى
الفلسطينيين وخياراتهم في تامين حمايه
لهم اي كتائب مسلح او مقاومين مسلحين
وبالتالي لا يوجد من ادوات لان يحموا
عائلاتهم سوى ادوات منزليه كما ذكرت لك قد
لا تتعدى عصي او قد لا تتعدى ادوات مطبخ
فقط لحمايه اطفالهم الذين يعني تصني الان
رسائل مناشده عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الاهالي يناشدون اي احد بالتدخل والوصول
لمسانده الاهالي لا يوجد اي امكانيه
لهؤلاء
العائلات والشبان من حمايه ابنائهم الا
بكما ذكرت لك بوسائل
بدائيه هي من ادوات المنزل وعليه من هذه
حت يعني لا يوجد كتائب مسلحه لا يوجد
مقاومون مسلحون ليحموا حتى الاهالي لا
يوجد حتى في واره لجان مقاومه هي تحت
سيطره اسرائيليه وبالتالي هي تحت سيطره
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وفق القوانين يجب من
ان يقوم
بتامين هم الاحتلال
للفلسطينيين كونهم يخضعون لسيطره الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ولكن هم لا يقدموا شيء يعني
ذكرت في ال وراينا عبر الصور المستوطنون
مسلحون يعني ليس فقط ان الاحتلال يحميهم
وكل هذه الكتائب تابعه لقوات الاحتلال بل
حتى ان السلاح الذي يملكه المستوطنون وكما
ذكرت لك نحن كنا نتابع عن كسب وكنا في
بلده حواره نرى يوميا كيف يتحرك المستوطن
بسلاحه بكل حريه دون اي واعز دون اي
مراقبه دون وكنا نع وكنا استمعنا في
السابق لوزراء اليمين في ه هذه الحكومه
المتطرفه كيف يطالب بن دفير وغيره بتسليح
المستوطنين باعطاء صلاحيه كامله لاي
مستوطن ليس فقط لاي جندي او شرطي باطلاق
النار بزعمي انه يجب ان يدافع عن نفسه
وبالتالي الخشيه الان من تطور الامور اكثر
فاكثر لا نعرف ماذا سيحث الساعات القادمه
ونحن ك كنا نشاهد هذه الصلوات التلموديه
التي يقوم بها المستوطنون في الطريق في
حواره وربما هنا من المفيد ان نسال يعني
انت ذكرتي ان المنطقه يتحكم بها الاحتلال
ولكن هذه الطريق التي رايناها حيث تتم هذه
الصلوات وكانها سوق وفيه محلات هل هناك اي
تواجد اسرائيلي في تلك المنطقه
بخلاف تواجد الاحتلال التواجد العسكري
للاحتلال هناك حتى يخرج هؤلاء المستوطنين
الى تلك المنطقه و ايه يؤدوا فيها هذه
الصلوات
التلموديه في هذه المنطقه في هذه القريه
وقريه بيتا القريبه
و اللبد وغيرها من القرى المحيطه ببلده
حواره لا يسكن فيها الا السكان
والمواطنين الفلسطينيين ولكن المستوطنين
ياتون من المستوطنات القريبه كمستوطنة
من اكثر المستوطنات مساحه وسيطره وايضا
مستوطنه ارئيل القريبه التي اصلا هي تحولت
وكانها مدينه ولكن ما يحدث فعليا على
حواره هو نموذج لعمليه النظام الفصل
العنصري وفق ما اكدته الكثير من المؤسسات
الدوليه لانه فقط لنشرح الموقع حيث بلده
حواره هناك حاجز حواره العسكري من من
الشمال وحاجز زعتره من الجنوب في الوسط
هناك شارع رئيسي يمر عبره المستوطنون في
هذه الايام الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ينهي
عمليه اكمال طرق وشوارع لربط المستوطنات
ببعضها وبالتالي ادخالها في داخل الخط
الاخضر اذا الفلسطينييون في حواره والكره
المحيطه هم محاطون تماما وكانهم داخل سياج
استيطاني وعسكري بالكامل كافه الجهات
وبالتالي المستوطنون نم يستطيعون الوصول
الى هذه المنطقه دون اي اشكاليه وكما تحت
حمايه قوات الاحتلال جيار جيفارا البديري
مراسله الجزيره من رام الله طبعا تبقين
معنا لموافاتنا بكل جديد فيما يتعلق بهذه
الاحداث المتلاحقه في حواره وهجوم
المستوطنين بحمايه من قوات الاحتلال على
الفلسطينيين بهذه المتابعه للتطورات
العاجله من الضفه الغربيه مشاهدينا ننهي
جوله الحصاد لهذه الليله اشكر لكم
متابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا